foreign 4
000 Asylum Seekers packed inside manston
buses were seen coming and going from
the processing center though this one
leaving didn't appear to have many
passengers on board
through gaps in the fence we saw men
women and young children in a camp where
we've been told unrest is spreading
fueled by Dreadful conditions and the
inability to leave
there are now around 30 giant Marquees
housing Asylum Seekers
but a senior member of the prison
Officers Association who visited the
camp 12 days ago and has members working
inside told us he believes the Army
which has no involvement in public order
may have to expand its role
tensions arise in the populations
getting bigger and bigger there's
nowhere to move these people onto I
think that eventually we'll see a
serious serious breakdown in public
order what does that mean potentially a
riot How concerned are you for the
Safety and Security of your members our
members are fiercing
threats from people who are you know
people constantly seeing them what's
happening to me where am I going when
will I be getting moved on eventually
when when our members can't give them an
answer people start making threats to uh
to to sit down to have sit-down protests
people are making threats to go on
Hunger Strike people make threats of
self-harm
it's difficult to speak to people inside
the campus they've had their phones
taken off them but two Sudanese 16 year
olds who said they were in manston
around a month ago gave us this
description of their experience the
teenagers have now been moved to hotels
in London
there are no beds in the tents not even
chairs we used to put the food boxes on
the floor and sleep on them I spent all
the time in the clothes they gave me
when I arrived and they were wet with
rain water a skin disease spread during
most day and I was afraid of getting
infected with it there are people still
in this place and they need medical care
the winter is Harsh and there is no warm
place to sleep you must help them
I spent 17 days in manston I slept on a
blanket and was covered with another
blanket which was not enough for me and
I was feeling the cold
there were daily fights between people
during my stay
record migrant arrivals and a shortage
of places to house them mean there's
little sign if this crisis being easily
resolved and even after being
transferred to Temporary accommodation
Asylum Seekers will face lengthy weights
for their claims to be processed Lisa
Holland Sky News